bleonard way popular radio host WEEI in
boston kind enough to join us if I told
you a week ago that Tom Brady was going
to Tampa you would have said what Glenn
I would have said there's a possibility
Dan but the world is upside down the
bars are closed the restaurants are
closed and the New England Patriots and
now just like another NFL franchise I
mean it's all foreign to us up here it's
totally different year is connected with
Bill Belichick is anybody in that market
did you get any indication before this
was happening as you know in the
dealings of Ed Wood bill bill doesn't
give away an awful lot the one thing I
will say is I thought all along there
was the possibility that Bill Belichick
was looking at this and saying the
problem was not the weapons we had
around Tom Brady the problem was Tom
Brady we didn't get enough of him during
the course of the week the elbow issue
presented a situation where Stidham was
getting the reps on Thursday and Friday
and I would not be surprised at all
because people keep on talking about
Daulton and all these other guys I would
not be surprised at all if Bill
Belichick is watching Jarrod Stidham
every day and he's looking at it and
saying this kid can play in the NFL
there's probably more to the story than
we know do you think that Belichick
wanted this situation no I think he
wanted Tom Brady back I think he wanted
Tom Brady on a year-to-year situation
because bill is very pragmatic he looks
at the statistics sometimes in odds and
let's face it there's only one
quarterback in the history of the
National Football League that has won a
game at age 43 or above and that's Vinny
Testaverde he won - nobody has started
more than eight games at age 43
I think Bill's looking at all of that
information and he's saying okay I love
Bill I mean I love but Tom he's great
Easter epic he still can play at a
pretty high level but any day now it
could go south and so I don't want to
put myself in cap hell a year or two
years from now and find out that six
games into the season the elbow goes
tom is not the same I was wondering
about the coincidence maybe it's a
coincidence maybe it's not I asked Chris
Sims about this last hour that Tom goes
from a coach who's polar opposite with
personality style demeanor everything
about that is that just a coincidence in
your opinion I did get the coincidence
right now I think it's something that
you know Tom's probably talking about
with his buddies today saying hey this
might be kind of interesting you know
kind of a looser atmosphere on the other
hand there was nobody that was more
disciplined and played into that
structure of discipline than Tom Brady
he was pissed last year because he
didn't think the rookies the young kids
were serious enough and so I think that
he might be looking at it
smiling today but let's see how it plays
out you know once you get to to camp
with all of this I really think it came
down to Tampa Bay in that there weren't
a lot of takers out there I think most
NFL teams Dan were looking at it the
same way Belichick was he wants two or
three years at 30 million plus each year
we're gonna lock him in for three years
at age 43 44 45 I think that's the
biggest problem that Patriots add here
Tom Brady wants to play until he's 45
albeit the greatest player in the
history of the game but he wants to play
at at least 45 he also wants the love
and respect of being that greatest
player and Bill Belichick is operating a
franchise with a strict system of value
and every year we need to be competitive
to different agendas I don't think they
mean who has more pressure on them going
into this next season I would say back
here in New England it would be
Belichick I'm not sure that's going to
play out nationally I'm already seeing
that Vegas I don't know how they put the
odds up they're closed aren't they but
they're putting the odds up in Tampa Bay
is like the third highest on the board
people are going to talk about the Bucs
having you know hosting the Super Bowl
and actually playing in it
I think that's an awful lot of pressure
I really do for Tom Brady I I look at it
and say that Tampa Bay is now relevant
if I'm the glaziers I'm looking at it
saying we're now going to make an awful
lot of money
selling season tickets at a huge rate
many of them by the way are buying from
New England I've heard from those people
they're calling me up and they tell me
they're buying down there and they're
just gonna take the flights back and
forth well your fan base we we found
upset yesterday was anybody angry about
this a lot of and who are they angry at
well I think a lot of it was directed at
craft you know Robert is a wonderful guy
I he's been a great owner he's a great
business guy and I think behind closed
doors he's looking at this as a business
he also wants to be loved and once the
fan base to love him and he's hearing
Stephen a on the ESPN yesterday kind of
ripped him and ripped Belichick and he
calls him during the break and he says
be very clear if Tom wanted to stay then
we would have worked it out and he would
have remained a New England Patriot but
Tom wanted to leave and we got a lot of
calls of people saying what is he doing
you know and I do think there's
something to that but why are you trying
to spin it you know right now in that
direction so he's taking heat Belichick
will take heat the difference is
belcheck I don't think will care about
the heat he knows that he's going to be
judged on how the team plays over the
next three four five years and I think
he's going to be around for the next
five years if I could give you a Brady
Belichick or Kraft to interview on your
show how would you take today
dobry okay wait don't you think Bella
check would have an interesting take on
this oh he won't he won't tell you
anything dance okay you guys please
regardless total transparency no so you
see here to end the question what
happened you know what Bill's gonna say
greatest quarterback of all time he's
wonderful he meant everything to the
organization he's never going to reveal
it okay and I think even when he gets
before the microphones in the next month
or so it would not surprise me if he
says I already made my statement you
read much you still don't know about
Malcolm Butler so you're right it's not
you know I'm not gonna get any any dirt
from him somebody's going to give us the
back there'll be a thirty four thirty on
this eventually since we do a thirty
four thirty on everything there'll be a
thirty four thirty on Brady
you know versus bill and I guarantee you
he'll go to his great
poplar but see I think the Patriots made
the smart decision you know when when
Robert Kraft and and you know they you
want to spin it now because you don't
want to be the bad guys here hey if Tom
wanted to stay here well the reason why
Tom didn't want to stay there is you're
not gonna give him thirty million
dollars a year over the next three years
you made the decision for him Brady did
what you're supposed to do
I want this you're not giving it to me
I'm leaving absolutely and they wanted
to change the offense on him because the
offense is changing in the league right
now and I think they also want a cheap
quarterback because if you look at
Kansas City Baltimore that's how you do
it that's how Bill Belichick began this
dynasty with a cheap quarterback that
was in the sixth round it allowed him to
build the rest of the roster the roster
wasn't good enough last year certainly
the offense with Tom Brady and if Tom
Brady gets that big money you can't add
a single soul for the offense where are
you
Jared Stidham your starting quarterback
this season I think you might be I think
all of this talk about going out and
getting one of these guys and I think
you're going to find probably they'll
bring it bring in a veteran looks like
the supply out does the demand right now
with all these available quarterbacks
Dan so I guess he would bring in
whoever's one of the last ones standing
that's willing to come in real cheap but
I think he's going to try to go cheap
and add seven hundred and fifty thousand
bucks at quarterback and that allows you
as Kansas City has done and Baltimore's
done over the last couple of years if
you've got a cheap quarterback Jared
Goff out and with the Rams they were
able to do it cheap quarterback it
allows you to build everybody around him
Glenn thanks for joining us and good
luck with the masses today Thank You Ann
thank you to the boys all right one of
our favorites Glenn Ordway WEEI Boston
radio talk show host